Naruto's kakashi hatake is everything
anyone would want out of a 2000 arrow be
shown in he checks all the boxes of the
beautiful boy character type he's tall
and mysterious a spiky white hair and
his hyper competent and stylized in
battle being mysterious and aloof are
the foremost elements that make Kakashi
so compelling and nothing highlights his
mystery more than the omnipresent mask
obscuring the lower half of his face
many other ninjas in Naruto have
costumes that obscure part or all of
their face but the mystique around
Kakashi's reached the level of interest
to which no other character can compare
what are you hiding under that mask what
you want to know what's behind my mask
yeah a prevailing Naruto fan Theory
links the compulsory need for Kakashi to
mask his face back to his father Sakuma
also known as the White Fang of Konoha
the Hatake clan are a historically
significant one in the ninja village and
Sakuma was a legend in his own right
which meant his son Kakashi had a lot to
live up to after a mission gone wrong
when Kakashi was a child however Sakuma
opted to abandon the objective and pull
his team members out before their lives
could be lost for this act he was
vilified as a coward by the people of
Konoha in the aftermath the rejection by
his people drove Sakamoto to depression
and ultimately death Naruto fans like to
believe that the dual pressures of his
father's once illustrious legacy and his
subsequent downfall drive Kakashi to
obscure his face since he looks just
like his father
and may want to dampen the possibility
of immediate recognition naruto creator
Masashi Kishimoto has in the past
explained some of his rationale in
masking Kakashi's face and it's not
quite that exciting
Kishimoto has explained that since
ninjas are inherently mysterious people
he thought giving them masks would amp
up that enigmatic quality however
Kishimoto realized that masking everyone
would make illustrating expressions
difficult so the general concept was
abandoned and Kakashi became unique
whatever Kishimoto is original intent
it's safe to say that Kakashi's masked
face is now a running gag and denying
the audience and fellow characters a
look at his face is the punchline
everyone wants to know what's underneath
the mask
kakashi eat does he sleep with it on why
is it there these are all questions
posed by characters on the series and
such inquisition actually became the
focus of episode 101 of the anime in
English it's called gotta see gotta know
Kakashi sensei's true face Naruto Sasuke
and Sakura spend the entirety of the
episode scheming to catch Kakashi
without his mask on
Kakashi however is immediately wise to
the stocking and deliberately fix them
out at every turn at the end of the
episode Naruto true to form explodes and
simply demands to know what Kakashi has
under his mask
Kakashi finally lets him in on the
secret behind this mask is another mask
pretty cool huh
that's it that's the episode over a
decade later another flashback episode
revisits the team's eternal struggle to
know what's beneath Kakashi's mask the
episode has Naruto Sakura and Sasuke
still wondering what their teacher looks
like when they're approached by a local
photographer named
sukhiya he too is very interested in
getting pictures of Kakashi without his
mask on it would be the biggest scoop of
his journalism career in Konoha after
all after more convoluted misadventures
the kids fail once again in their task
and give up however
sukhiya has been Kakashi in a wig and
makeup the whole time it's the Clark
Kent twist nobody recognizes him with
the mask off the kids never learn the
truth and Kakashi says he wants to mess
with them more before fessing up but at
last we know what he looks like
there's no big shock to it he looks
perfectly normal but he might be a
little shy around the mole you can see
on his jaw there's no need for him to
feel embarrassed the mark is distinctive
and adds character what's a little
beauty mark in the grand scheme check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]